guys uh I hit a Mount Rushmore
a Mount Rushmore of my life uh two weeks
ago actually two weeks ago yesterday
I became best friends with Bill Murray I
know we saw pictures yeah we talked
about it we saw people we talked about
it and did you Taco pointed out that uh
it didn't look like the normal
selfie where you know you ambushed him
and he was not happy about it he
actually looked like you were having a
conversation we had a long long
conversation and uh I'll just tell you
my Bill Murray story really quick
quickly because I love telling this
story
um so we're at the Phoenix show and I'm
talking to the guy after the show that
from Phoenix the bass player from
Phoenix and he's a sweetheart and I love
this band so much so we're just chatting
about the band and going back and forth
and he looks over my shoulder and goes
oh look there's Bill Murray
and I go no no it's not give me a break
don't worry it's not here I'm not even
turning around to justify what you just
said because again and not again not
again and then he goes he goes but
seriously it's Bill Murray and I turn
around I see Bill Murray I turn back to
the Phoenix Sky said see you later and I
run to Bill Murray and so we get to Bill
and he's like he's getting he's getting
manhandled by this woman and I she just
won't let him out of her grasps right so
he talk and talk and talk and talk and
so I'm not going to interrupt them so he
we take a lap around the room we come
back to Bill Murray and by that time
there is the there's these dudes who are
uh like like bro dudes and they break up
the conversation they're you know being
jerks and then Bill Murray gets the wife
my wife to take a picture
of them and you know she may she cracks
a joke makes Bill Murray laugh and that
gives us the end to go after Bill Murray
and so we start talking and and
I I can't explain to you it's like he
was right out of Central Casting if
somebody were to cast Bill Murray he's
the perfect Bill Murray he's everything
that you think that he is he's he's
Charming he's hysterical
um so I start I start just cracking
jokes I call him prime minister nice to
meet you prime minister uh people walk
up to him like this is Gary Murray don't
tell anybody and he he starts to really
start cocking his head it's like what is
going on with this dude and then finally
I start petting him
you touched it very he's very wearing a
very fluffy shirt so I'm petting him and
I look at he he looks at me he's like
what are you doing I was like I'm
petting Bill Murray
you can't wear a fluffy shirt if you if
you're Bill Murray because everyone will
want to pet don't worry
and he just loses it and
every time he he would leave he'd come
right back to me and he'd hold his arm
out and say you want to pet Bill Murray
yes I do yes I would like to Pat don't
worry and so then we struck up another
conversation we talked about Letterman
of course you know my hero in life and
we talk about golf we talked about his
first pitch at the Cubs game years ago
when he throws the ball over the fence
um you know we had we talked a good I I
mean I'm not trying to overstate this a
good half an hour and I just had this
moment of like I I just
I was in awe the whole the rest of the
night the rest of the night is kept
spinning around saying to myself I
cannot believe
on the and the thing I didn't tell him
you see all these posters behind me well
the one that's hanging in my house in
Chattanooga right now is a poster of
Bill Murray
I've got a Bill Murray poster in my
house and on the bottom it says ladies
and gentlemen Bill Murphy signed Dave
Letterman and you know he's just been on
a Mount Rushmore of my life for I got
since the moment I ever saw him on
Letterman so
um
so with all that being said you know
Barry you know me well enough there's
only one left there's only one more left
who is it I think you just said his name
it's Dave yeah I only need one more and
I'll be and I'll be Lord Taco happy
check check me out of this life I'm good
to go I only need Dave and I've got the
I've got the Mount Rushmore of human
beings that I have been able to meet in
my life and that's I I can't believe it
I just can't believe it and when you
when you think about all like the Crazy
Bill Murray stories that you've heard
right right when you know he shows up at
a
at a frat party and starts doing dishes
right you know
um I had a guy uh you walk he walks up
to somebody and takes a bite out of
their hamburger and just walks away you
know like I know some of these have like
created their own living legend right
but it's because he's a you know he's
that character he's exactly that person
and so one time I heard the story from a
buddy of mine who goes uh he goes I was
I was standing at this I can't remember
where he was like the map room or chart
room I mean it was Matt this map room in
um in Chicago and all of a sudden he had
these hands go over his eyes from behind
and and whispered into his ear the guy
behind him says this is Bill Murray no
one will ever believe you
[Laughter]
hands away turns around and sees Bill
Murray just walk away from him I mean he
just that kind of guy and he's exactly
that person when you meet him I I was
I've been giddy for two weeks ever since
that's cool that's cool when I saw the
pictures I I think I told Taco I said
I'm not surprised it seems like
something Bill Murray would do he loves
that kind of stuff yeah it was totally
totally appropriate yeah
yeah exactly good for you yeah well I
mean look I mean if you see Bill Murray
you have to figure out a way to get a
picture and I just didn't want to do the
regular I don't know
not sure I would have laid hands on him
but good for you
I don't know if a petting was where I
would go
advise it for most people
okay do you think that he's going to
remember the PBR guy or the guy that pet
him randomly on a Friday night if you're
lucky there wasn't you know Authority
authorities called yeah
he touched me